joining me now is Saul weisenberg former
deputy independent Council former
assistant U.S attorney and Mike Davis
president and founder of the article 3
project now Saul back in April
it was reported that
um the doj was looking at four charges
so is this right what we heard from all
those commentators that this is just
kind of par for the course the other two
go away and this this is how it all kind
of you know plays out in a play
we don't have enough facts yet Laura to
know if it's a sweetheart deal but it's
certainly a sweet deal for for Hunter
Biden and it doesn't look very normal to
me at all we don't have the plea
agreement yet or What's called the
factual basis which is part of it so I
withhold final judgment but I can tell
you uh that it is unusual to let an
individual get pre-trial diversion on a
felony gun charge and particularly here
where in addition to that you've got two
tax misdemeanors that they've charged I
also want to make this point which is he
was charged with willful failure to pay
taxes that's a misdemeanor but the
felony of tax evasion takes very little
additional additionally to prove the
only additional element there is that
there is a affirmative Act of
concealment and under the case law the
case law is very broad on what that act
could be it could be as simple as lying
to an IRS agent or filling out something
incorrectly on that tax return so all of
that leads me to really want to ask a
lot more questions and then the final
question is if you're going to give
somebody a sweet deal like this did you
put him under oath and bring in the Pro
and bring in people who might be
investigating the broader Biden family
issues and say buddy if you want to deal
like this you're going to talk to us for
a long time you're going to proffer with
us
now Mike when you think about how this
all ends up playing out it is a way for
the Democrats to say
well Justice was done
right there this was a process and the
process played out and kind of get it
off the table for the election that
sounds very cynical I realize for me to
say that but given how people now a lot
of people believe this justice
department operates
you can understand that feeling because
it's hard to imagine that Republic a
republican front-runner son with a
felony gun charge would be able to kind
of sweep it sweep it onto the rug with
two years probation
Justice was not done here a cover-up was
completed by the Biden justice
department and this David Wiese who the
left-wing media says was a trump
appointee that's it's not that simple
the two Democrat senators in Delaware
picked him as their U.S attorney I was
the chief counsel for nominations when
he went through the process I know that
they're the ones who picked him and
David Weiss has sat on evidence about
Biden's corruption for years he sat on
evidence protecting Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden for years and then they come to
this sweethearts deal where they're
going to cover up they're gonna they're
gonna essentially cover up 2017 and 2018
tax evasion by Hunter Biden and his
business partner was Joe Biden when he
allegedly took they both allegedly took
a 10 million dollar bribe from barisma
and changed U.S policy this is a
cover-up plain and simple now Saul the
doj says that the investigation is
ongoing but hunter Biden's attorney
feels differently watch this my
understanding is that we're done I think
there's going to be a court proceeding I
think there are going to be agreements
that are going to come out about the
court proceeding and I think we'll
everyone will see what happens once that
occurs would you make a deal though if
you thought there were more charges
coming would I make a deal yeah uh no I
wouldn't
so what do you make of that
sounds like he's a pretty good
white-collar defense attorney and he
certainly got a good deal for his client
and I've heard the theory uh that the
reason doj said that is because it's
easier to resist Congressional demands
for information when you've got an
ongoing investigation and I find that
very plausible but but again
when you talk about a possible further
investigation one thing for sure this is
a very very beneficial deal for Hunter
Biden and I would like to know what they
demanded of him and what Forum under
oath in front of a grand jury a recorded
interview in order to get his
information and did they even attempt to
do that you know a lot of times I've
talked about this for years when we talk
about IG Michael Horowitz it's how
broadly you define the investigation
from the beginning it looks like this
was defined very narrowly from what we
can tell
again Mike the cynics thinking on this
is that if you didn't know better you
would think that almost Joe Biden knew
that this was going to play out this way
I mean he very boldly took his son
on that you know overseas trip recently
he's been and out of the White House a
lot right if you if you thought your son
truly was vulnerable to you know jail
time and felony prosecution maybe you
wouldn't have done that or is that just
again we're just so negative on on these
you know law enforcement agencies and
doj in particular yeah so Biden's
attorney general wants president Trump
to die in prison over a fight with
Biden's Librarians and bureaucrats over
presidential records Biden's attorney
general doesn't want the president's son
to spend a day in prison for Clear tax
evasion in a clear gun felony
Saul and Mike thank you for both for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else